you fool the dark days as I was I was I
was thinner than you so he decided I
just have a different meaning I gave him
a bunch of pictures Hennigan here the
the The Scotsman I pulled out I pulled
my dick out in front of Bert Kreischer
on a podcast two nights ago I remember I
can't remember why we were so [ __ ]
I've been begging him not to air it cuz
I don't know what I said but I'd seen
Ahri's dick about a hundred times well
so for the book I sent a bunch of
pictures with Hennigan to pick and
choose and then they took all these dick
pics of me in public and I like you
can't have all the picture sections just
my dick so I had to decide so this one I
decided on this not having any idea it
could be so perfectly timed the top one
is me with my dick out in a kilt in
front of a blind guy at karaoke while
he's singing having no idea but the one
below it is me starting to pull my dick
out in front of louis c.k oh my jerk off
in front of the abusers Wow did you
fight in crime I didn't have to block
the door he didn't block the door folks
by the way that's not that's not real
apparently that's like something that
like gets passed on like an urban myth
that juices up the story I'm saving this
for tomorrow I'm doing dork forest with
Jackie Kashian and Laurie Kilmartin so
I'm saving the bulk of my Laurie kill my
louis c.k for that just because they're
ladies I want they're against solid
opinion but I I mean I have to make this
so spacious timewise because I don't
want to out the person but I was doing
comedy and I was a comedian I I knew
back in the day when we were young in
another millennium just blame it on
Ralphie she said you're never gonna
guess what I just did I just watched
louis c.k jerk off in the ladies room
and I went wow she goes yeah I said hey
would you she's like I don't care and as
we've caught up many many years later
she goes yeah I just did it because it
was funny I really I did it because it
was a story to tell
right and I said he you coming forward
cuz afterwards when she said what she
told me that I go
you never watch me jerk off you know
watch me jerk up I pull my dick out put
on poor did she watch you know she just
said yeah I don't care whatever she's
like it's no fun if you don't watch the
way I remembered is that she remembers
me saying if you don't like it don't
look either way it was just a goof you
were I think you have to stand up to I
think what we should do to normalize
this whole Louise hang on this is the
important part of this is when I said
are you gonna come out she can't because
she just did it cuz it was funny right
of course and she would almost be put in
a place where she would be as it's
people like you that made him into a
monster like right it was kind of a goof
back that no one cared it's only weird
and it was very polite so when I heard
the louis c.k stories later on i just
assumed it was like that yeah he was
very polite hey would you watch me jerk
off well I had heard from someone else
that had talked to someone gotten like
the story from Louie and their version
of it through the grapevine so don't
take this as like verbatim was something
along the lines of no it was just he
thought it was silly to like pull his
dick out and take pictures with them and
that I had heard that he was saying that
it was and he didn't actually masturbate
in front of them
that was like one version of it so I was
like okay well maybe that was what and
then the full story came out and I was
like okay and then someone had said yeah
but he asked them first along with this
this is another important beat is me my
story happened before he was in any
position of power other than comics
looked up to him he was still writing
for comics that might have had some
power at best I don't think it was a
power thing necessarily so if you're a
man and you have a you're alone in a
room with a woman and this is my
perception of it it's always a power
thing because it's [ __ ] weird cuz you
can kill them it's different like have
you ever been around like a UFC athlete
some big giant this was a place where
you go if you if this was a tinder date
this happened in a place where you'd go
I want to meet you in public I don't
want to be so yeah
it was completely safe yeah but if you
know other times if you're alone in a
room with a man it's like being and you
know that a man has like some sexual
urges directed towards you and you're a
woman it becomes a vulnerable situation
and if there's some weird [ __ ] where
someone if let's just say someone was
blocking the door because I had heard
that Louis didn't block any doors then
it becomes really crazy like what do you
do well first of all you're hearing yes
yeah well it's also like I think the
thing that people have the hardest time
with all of this is you never want to
think that it's possible that someone
would do something horrible to somebody
if you like them yeah right like with
all of this with anything whether it's
Kevin Spacey or any these people like
maybe you like him as an actor I like
that guy he's great on house of cards
wait a minute she really just
terrorizing people and grabbing dicks
everywhere [ __ ]
yeah I can make some people time I do
too I do too I come grab asses and dicks
oh that's not what I do but I know I
think about it that way at my house one
way oh when you guys we had a party the
other night I go who have I not groped
inappropriately there okay wait
Gil I haven't done it to you and I
grabbed his dick just to make sure it
we're all [ __ ] good never groped me
I'm starting to feel a little left out I
don't think nothing I don't even think
you've ever gone for my but I might have
old gold it from afar I think you
might've spanked me once but the point
being it's like come on we got it just
people have to figure out some way to
interface with each other 100% of the
time as equal and just work on your own
[ __ ] but what the way you talk to
people like somebody brought this up
once that they had an issue with a lot
of this stuff is that it's someone in
the same business that's in this like
position of being like a great artist
like Kevin Spacey type character or
whatever and then the other person is
like a PA or something like that he
preys on them yeah and it's his show and
he they can't get away and he's like
attacking them and they're straight he's
gay
absolutely I know that 100% I think
that's some weird almost like reptilian
instinct
that human I can't tell you how many
times we've had to because you know my
audience mm-hmm over-served quite a bit
of the time and when it's a girl that's
alone you can see the packs of guys oh
I'll get you you I'll give you a ride
where do you live exactly all right
let's get her in uber because I know
that's gonna go poorly